yesterday our Union celebrated the 90th
anniversary of the incorporation of
Screen Actors Guild during our nearly
century-long existence we've fought for
and achieved countless gains for working
actors
today we embark on a new important
chapter in our Union's history earlier
this morning the sagafter national board
convened following four weeks of
negotiations with the alliance of motion
picture and television producers the
amptp
because the amptp remains unwilling to
offer a fair deal on key issues
essential to protecting the livelihoods
of working actors and performers
sagathra's national board unanimously
voted to issue a strike order against
the studios and streamers